sky saucers have revealed that Jamal
Hajis body parts have apparently been
found we know that the Turkish
authorities were looking in a forest
area on the outskirts of Istanbul for
these body parts and that apparently
something has been found in the last
couple of hours we heard from the
Turkish president President Erdogan who
pointed the finger very very clearly at
the Saudi authorities and said that he
had a number of questions that he wanted
the Saudi authorities to answer in the
last couple of moments Saudi Arabia has
said that it will hold a count those
responsible for her Shah jees killings
whoever they are this is according to
the Saudi king or let's cross to our
correspondent Eric's Warford who is in
Istanbul and Alex tell us about the
latest that you found well we've been
speaking to a number of sources both
very well-placed sources within the
investigation and also within political
circles and they've been telling us
separately first of all that Jamarcus
Shah jees body parts have been
discovered they had been cut up I
understand there's some fairly grisly
detail about how his face had been
disfigured somewhat there is a
suggestion from the second source he is
very very highly placed as I say within
political circles and he has connections
within the prosecutor's office that
those body parts were discovered in the
garden of the Consul generals home we're
just outside the property this the
Consul generals property was part of a
focus a very big focus of the forensic
investigators they took some time to get
in it into it more than two weeks later
we ourselves witnessed some of those
forensic investigators examining the
garden we know that they took soil
samples from there and the
they were trying to match DNA samples
taken of Jamal GOG with samples that
they collected inside the Consul
generals residence
other reports suggested and we know from
CCTV footage that parts of the 15 man
so-called Saudi hit squad there was a
lot of movement between the consulate
and the Consul generals residents with
vehicles being moved particularly they
focused on a number of vehicles which
had diplomatic plates and had darkened
windows and which were seen reversing
into the back behind that security block
you can there is a garage a carport we
saw the cars reversing into there and
they then stayed there for a number of
hours the investigators were focusing on
what was in the car what was being
transported into the Consul generals
residence according to our sources in
that car or certainly what was being
transported to the Consul General
residents were parts of Jamal kichaka's
body having been cut up now the the line
being perpetuated from the Saudis is
that the body was rolled up in a rug and
handed to a local collaborator and the
Turkish president made a big point of
this in his speech earlier today say
throwing quite a lot of and hinting at
quite a lot of skepticism about whether
this local collaborator existed at all
and suggesting that the Saudis needed to
give them much more information about
who this local collaborator was so that
the he and the investigators could be
led to the bot to the body and the
corpse I understand so he was directly
contradicting what our sources of later
told us to be fair those sources only
revealed that information to us after
the president had spoken and there is a
suggestion that perhaps the body parts
could have been spread over a number of
different addresses you mentioned
earlier that one point of focus was also
bail
great forests in Istanbul as well as an
address near the Sea of Marmara which is
some distance way about an hour and a
half's drive away we know according to
what President Erdogan said in his
address this morning that an advance
party of about three Saudis went out and
was spotted investigating the forest
ahead of demolish Ali's killing on
October the second